aujourd'hui ce paris sg dont on s'est
encore jamais parlé de problèmes
d'audition c'est un sujet social et qui
potentiellement nous touchera tous à un
moment ou un autre de notre vie on
pourrait se dire qu'est ce que tu nous
fais tu viens nous parler de dition
aujourd'hui sur une chaise tagba
justement c'est intéressant parce que ce
qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui c'est
comment est ce que la technologie vient
résoudre des problèmes de société des
problèmes de santé avec de
l'intelligence artificielle avec plein
de technologies ça permet d'ailleurs
d'aller beaucoup plus loin que raison
des propositions messager vous expliquer
parce que au-delà du problème d'audition
purs et durs tels qu'on peut l'imaginer
vous avez peut-être des parents des
grands parents qui souffrent de
problèmes d'audition sacré de
l'isolément social quand on entend pas
bien on a du mal à avoir une
conversation et si on n'a pas la bonne
solution le bon appareillage c'est très
compliqué aussi de maintenir une
conversation et encore plus lors de
grandes réunions de famille parce que
c'est très fatigant parce qu'elle espèce
de brouhaha et c'est compliqué et c'est
même un sujet qui peut toucher beaucoup
de personnes à différents âges de la vie
puisqu'ils perdent audition peut arriver
suite à un traumatisme et sa touche
d'ailleurs beaucoup de personnes d'où
l'importance d'être appareillé mais des
biens appareiller avec des solutions des
solutions hyper intéressantes comme
celle qu'on va voir aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle oticon morts
ce sujet de la perte d'audition c'est un
sujet qui est super important parce que
ça permet de se réapproprier le monde
qu'on a autour de soi quelqu'un qui
n'entend plus ou qui entend mal pas
forcément être coupé du monde et isoler
du monde un moment parce que moment vous
avez la perte d'audition soit ça arrive
suite à un traumatisme et là vous avez
une perte franches et nettes soit ça
arrive tout doucement et c'est ce qui se
passe la plupart du temps sur des pertes
auditives liées à l'âge c'est au début
une gêne puis progressivement une perte
d'audition et même parfois il ya des
acouphènes par dessus donc ce qui est
important c'est d'apporter une bonne
solution pour venir compenser cette
perte auditive est ici notamment avec le
réseau neuronal profond ça c'est votre
oreille enfin quelque chose presse
est-elle pas réellement votre oreille
mais en tout cas sa seule une oreille et
l'aurait qu'est ce que ça fait eh bien
ça vient récupérer des son est à dire
des vibrations dans l'air et ça vient
conduire directement ici et au final ça
vient convertir le signal acoustique en
signal électrique et comment ça se passe
ça si votre oreille le ce on arrive ici
de l'extérieur et valère votre oreille
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle fait votre
oreille et bien elle va conduire le son
directement au cerveau et le cerveau il
est là naturellement lorsque vous avez
quand même problème auditif vous captez
tous les sons autour de vous lorsque
vous êtes dans un environnement bruyant
et vous par là dès qu'une personne vous
arrivez à faire abstraction du bruit
autour de vous en vous concentrant sur
la personne avec qui vous êtes en train
de parler en l'occurrence tout de suite
c'est vous et ce travail là il se fait
parce que votre cerveau en est capable
sauf que du moment où vous perdez de
l'audition et bien tout devient plus
compliqué donc si vous entendez bien il
n'y a pas de souci mais si vous entendez
mal et que vous êtes mal appareiller
voilà ce qui se passe c'est à dire que
le son il est réceptionné ici et
l'appareil qui est l'interface entre le
monde extérieur et votre oreille et des
caisses qui va faire lui il va réhausser
d'un niveau pour vous envoyer la purée
pleine balle dans vos oreilles et que
vous entendez tout d'un coup sauf que
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça parce
que là ça vous envoie une espèce de
bouillabaisse directement dans l'oreille
la bouillabaisse elle vient jusqu'à
votre cerveau et votre cerveau et noyés
parce que c'est le bordel alors certes
quand vous êtes dans une scène comme là
où il ya une seule personne qui vous
parle eh bien on comprend pas ce que ça
vient juste amplifié ma voix mais si
vous retrouver dans un monde très
bruyant s'amplifie tout la voie au
milieu c'est très compliqué de venir
discriminer juste la voix et dans tant
de capter juste la boit et c'est
justement là où la solution nous parle
aujourd'hui qui est oticon mort est
intéressante pourquoi parce que oticon
mort ce qu'elle va faire va récupérer le
signal à l'analyser grâce à ce qu'on va
appeler un réseau neuronal profond en
fait ça se passe comme dollars étaient
légion artificielle si vous voulez ça va
faire comme notre cerveau qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire chier oticon ils ont
analysé des tonnes de seine ils ont posé
un micro omnidirectionnel quatre leçons
de tous les côtés ils ont analysé
jusqu'à 12 millions de scène quasiment
tout au danemark parce qu'ils aiment
bien le danemark des danois c'est normal
ils font ça chez eux maison en fait
aussi un petit peu à l'extérieur et aux
finalistes pasqua eh bien il se passe
que lorsque vous êtes dans un moment
comme ça ou bien il n'y a pas beaucoup
de bruit il va amplifier la voix et vous
retrouverez votre voix ça va passer par
votre oreille ça allait à votre cerveau
et lui va comprendre c'est de la voix
c'est très facile mais si lorsqu'on dans
un endroit qui est extrêmement bruyant
et déjà faire un focus sur la voie il va
venir l'interprète est directement pour
vous envoyer ce dont vous avez
réellement besoin à ce moment là mais si
à ce moment là une autre personne
arrivée vous parle sans le côté réseau
neuronal profonds ont quatre la deuxième
voie on vient amplifier et on distribue
le sont de façon intelligente parce qu à
la différence d'une correction optique
pour vos yeux ou on vous corrige une
bonne fois pour toute quel que soit
l'endroit où vous allez regarder
l'audition c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce qu'il faut s'adapter en permanence
à toutes les scènes il ya des scènes qui
sont très très complexe un environnement
bruyant du son qui vient de tous les
côtés et c'est ça que va faire oticon
mort grâce à son réseau neuronal profond
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait c'est du
brain irrigue qu'est ce qui se cache
derrière ce nom un petit peu marre marre
c'est de l'apprentissage du cerveau
comment fonctionne seul techno ça se
passe aux technologies qu'on va appeler
le big data alors qu'est ce que c'est
que le big data si vous intéressez à la
tête vous savez probablement ce que c
est bien ce sont des informations qui
sont stockées ici je vous ai dit il ya
12 millions de seine ça veut donc dire
que oticon morts on reconnaît ici dans
cette banque de données 12 millions de
scènes différentes pour mettre en place
des corrections qui permettront de
s'adapter à la vie de tous les jours et
à plein de scènes qu'elles soient
complexes ou non il ya un espèce de
parallèles entre votre cerveau et le
réseau neuronal profond qui est
constitué un peu comme des neurones
artificiels bon en un peu moins bien
fait que votre cerveau parce que le
cerveau quand même bien mieux fait mais
ça permet d'apprendre et d'appliquer
ensuite si vous avez une mauvaise
protection auditive qu'est ce qui se
passe vous avez un des ford écoute donc
une plus grosse charge cognitive de la
fatigue ça demande une réorganisation
des fonctions cérébrales et à terme ça
accélère le déclin cognitif autant dire
que c'est globalement vraiment pas très
très bon d'où l'importance des dden
appareils comment ça se passe chez
oticon mort eh bien vous avez des
appareils et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont venir
faire l'un des jobs en a pour tous les
goûts les rendent si vous aimez heureuse
vous aurez un appareil rose si vous
aimez gri gri bref y en a pour tout le
monde je tiens à préciser sont des
appareils factice je n'ai pas de vrais
appareils c'est histoire d'illustrer le
propos alors qu'est-ce qui se passe eh
bien il se passe que vous avez votre
appareil qui est située sur votre
oreille ça c'est votre oreille donc le
son art il il passe ici il ya deux
micros en fait 1,2 micro qui vont venir
capter le son il va venir modifier la
captation de ce qu'il entend par rapport
à votre oreille parce que oui vous
n'êtes pas sages c'est ça notre duo
prothésiste d'abord donc on connaît
votre audition on connaît votre oreille
ensuite vous avez le spatial baleine
soeur qui va venir analyser et localiser
jusqu'à 24 sources différentes il va
reconnaître le bruit la parole mais
aboiements d'un chien le banc de chat
les pleurs d'un bébé si quelqu'un vous
parle il va venir diminuer les bruits et
faire vraiment le focus sur la parole il
va analyser tous les spectres 200 hertz
jusqu'à 10000 et hertz et ça il le fait
cinq cents fois par seconde et ils vous
donnent 250 correction par seconde une
fois que lui il a fait ce job ici il
soumet tout ça au réseau neuronal
profond qui lui va filtrer et adapter en
permanence et ensuite vous avez le
spatial et dancer qui va être une
adaptation fine en fonction de chaque
patient et oui on est tous différent en
fonction de votre âge de vos capacités
cognitives ici on se base sur
technologie qui s'appelle paul harris
qu'à seize fois plus de capacité à
exécuter des algorithmes complexes bref
je vous passe un peu côté technique ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'ici vous
avez un max de technologies qui vont
servir à améliorer l'audition et donc la
santé pas vraiment cette illustration
est super important comment est-ce que
technologies vient d'apporter vrais
bénéfices au niveau de la santé mais
c'est bien plus que ça puisqu'il est
apple ready pour pouvez donc le
connecter à votre iphone mais également
à un android disposant du protocole
achats android streaming fort et rolling
heads et vous permettra donc de venir
écouter de la musique directement avec
vos appareils plutôt pas mal et en plus
de ça il est compact d'être le protocole
http et https tech pas si vous
connaissez ça me permettra de venir
connecter différents appareils par
exemple vous pourrez savoir si vous avez
un pour connecter et bien quand votre
plat est amené dans le four vous aurez
une alerte dans vos appareils vous
pourrez lié également avec votre télé
connectée vous pourrez ouvrir la porte
du garage à distance fin bref il ya
plein de choses qui peuvent être faits
avec donc c'est un appareil qu'on
pourrait se dire qui est comme ça juste
un appareil auditif mais non pas du tout
c'est de l'intelligence c'est de la
connectivité c'est de la technologie
vous en douterez on parle de santé
connectés donc forcément il ya des
études cliniques qui ont été faites on
parle ici de 60% d'informations plus
avec une précision qui augmentait une
augmentation de 45% des informations que
je peux venir extraire 30% des voix qui
sont captés beaucoup plus facilement
même avec des changements de direction
donc ils vraie adaptation en temps réel
alors comment ça marche ou ça bien
évidemment bien par contre point on
parle d'appareil de santé la première
chose c'est d'aller voir un orl ensuite
aller voir un audioprothésiste lui
expliquer votre fonctionnement vos
besoins lui parler dottikon morts bien
évidemment l'essayer parce qu'il faut
commencer par essayer avant d'aller
acheter et ici on se parle d'un appareil
de classe 2 avec une partie qui est
prise en charge par la sécu est mutuel
la deuxième avec un reste à charge et si
on se parle d'un coup par appareil de
l'ordre de 1800 à 2000 euros et bien
évidemment il vous en faudra deux avec
un besoin de renouvellement tous les 4-5
ans et en plus c'est si on se parle
d'appareil qui sont montés à 90% la main
le but avec oticon mort c'est de
retrouver sa vie d'avant c'est de ne
plus sentir isolé de pouvoir converser
facilement de ne plus avoir peur d'aller
dans la rue de rencontrer quelqu'un
qu'on connaît en disant mince je vais
absolument rien comprendre je voulais
partager avec vous quelques petits
témoignages qui sont présents sur le
site de tikhon il y en a de kurt carte
qui a une trentaine d'années ça veut
donc dire que les pertes d'audition ça
peut toucher beaucoup de monde et et à
tout âge et lui en fait ce qui vous dit
c'est qu'il a des problèmes de surdité
depuis qu'il est gamin il le met juste
en une phrase j'aurais aimé que ces
aides auditives soit disponible quand
j'étais enfant vous arriver un autre de
mails mais qui dit je crois réellement
que mon expérience est proche de celle
des gens qui ont une audition normale
donc voyez l'idée c'est une fois de plus
de vouloir le retour à la vie normale et
notamment c'est possible aujourd'hui en
tout cas en partie grâce à cette
technologie et puis vous avez une
d'edwina qui dit ma qualité de vie au
quotidien a sûrement fait un bond en
avant notamment parce que je sais que je
peux continuer à travailler et c'est
vrai que souvent quand on parle de de
perte d'audition ce divin tiens c'est
vrai que ça ça concerne le troisième âge
les personnes âgées ça paraît aussi
naturel bien évidemment mais on se rend
pas compte que la question de la perte
auditive qui est une question de santé
publique ça peut toucher beaucoup de
monde et à tout âge et c'est vachement
rations et moi je me le dis aujourd'hui
je souffre pas de problèmes auditifs
mais je trouve ça extrêmement rassurant
de se dire que ok quand ça m'arrivera
parce que potentiellement arrivera un
moment ou un autre eh bien il existe des
solutions qui me permettent de continuer
à vivre normalement d'avoir d une vie
sociale des interactions sociales et pas
me retrouver isolé et moi qui en plus de
ça m'intéresse à la tech ça une
résonance supplémentaire parce que ça
peut être un moyen de devenir apporter
de l'aide à mes aînés et à mois plus
tard
d'ailleurs vous si vous avez des amis si
vous avez de la famille des personnes
peut-être même d'ailleurs vous qui
souffrait de pertes auditives à les
tester à les découvrir à les pousser la
porte d'un audioprothésiste et essayer
oticon mort découvrir pour vous ou pour
vos proches le bénéfice de cette
technologie la basé sur un réseau
neuronal profond qui permet de se
réapproprier le monde et son
environnement et pour en savoir plus je
vous invite tous les liens en bas d'un
description cliquez dessus allez jeter
un oeil des bisous à bientôt
[Musique]